hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm Grantland waifu and I have a
hot fortune to tell or at least one I
want to pick apart as we look at
episodes 50 and 51 of Hunter hunter
everything has sort of come to a head
and everything's pretty intense so strap
in prepare the springs to be pulled and
my life cuz you all seem to have seen
this before I mean I don't know to never
be the same again y'all I get names
right in this episode I do I promise
it'll take some tries but you might hear
a certain dead character's name said
correctly episode 50 gone baka gah
we weren't I hope any of us surprised to
see Gahan reacting to his Sokka being in
the room with the rest of the spiders
then he was saved by actually seeing
Shizuku who I wonder why she has such a
poor memory the arm wrestling that
occurred during this episode was a
beautiful scene and set up a lot of
premises it made really clear the idea
that the Phantom troupe really do more
than just work together they care about
each other too and nothing made that
more clear than Nobunaga not hmm
I do Nobunaga deciding to arm wrestle
gone over and over again in a form of
torture for his hand to be bleeding he
must either have been arm wrestling for
a long time or every bone in his hand
must be broken or both
most likely both when he finally won as
I suspected would happen it made perfect
sense to me that Nobunaga would want to
recruit him to the fans and troupe and
honestly if the Phantom troupe had found
him before karateka and the audio had I
wouldn't at all have been surprised if
he'd said yes and joined immediately
gone has a code of honor very similar to
the Phantom troupe it's just that he
happens to be aligned with the other
side
as soon as Nobunaga said Gahan was like
who go wait
as soon as Nobunaga said Gahan was like
Logan I understood entirely who Vogon
was and I understood a little more about
who Gahan was - the cute kiss on the
cheek from a few episodes ago the
inability to take defeat the sociopathic
tendencies they're all exactly what this
little boy is growing into he's even an
enhancer and it could just as well have
been revoked in talking to Nobunaga
about the death of someone he cared
about because that's exactly what he
would have done had any of the other
troupe members been hurt I find it odd
that becoming a member of the troupe is
something that can be forced surely one
scroll Oh returned the result would be
hey do you want to join the troupe
wait hang on he never speaks out loud
who do you want to join the truth
wait it's even lower than that hey do
you want to join the troop what kind of
powers does krolow have why is he the
leader
what makes his law so powerful all we've
seen is him looking down the lens at us
how does he keep them in line speaking
of keeping them in line let's discuss
the coin for a moment please
the idea that is part of their rules
they must flip a coin to make decisions
is a really interesting one partially
because they all adhere to it and don't
step outside that the intensity of the
tension in the room when know that I get
a name like I do
the intensity of the tension in the room
when Nobunaga decided he wanted to try
to recruit the boys was beautifully
animated and I wonder whether they're
all just really good at coin tricks at
this point tricks beyond literally
placing us between the legs of breasty
Magee which seems unnecessary and absurd
it does seem interesting how much
attention the rest of the group is
willing to place on park or Noda
touching to read memories is an
interesting skill and the fact that qi
picked up on it without it becoming
immediately important that he knew was
satisfying actually I just like to
briefly note that melody wasn't on the
troops hunting list so she is perfectly
safe from them unless she says something
about karateka herself we'll see I guess
but I can't see her doing that the
escape from Nobunaga was a great way to
show that only one of the two boys can
be fools at a time and reminded us that
Kea was dealing with some pretty intense
trauma I'm not entirely sure why illumi
came back to haunt Kilwa beyond being
trapped I wonder whether he sleeps with
the lights on the kids to be in the dark
is to end up in the dark pits of
aluminum or Ren or and I'm so confused
by these I'm sorry anyway I'm glad the
entire 20 minutes AG way of an episode
that was their introduction to
collecting was of some use despite it
being tiny it was great in a way that
they had this method of communication
and you know what it was nice that this
method of communication was accessible
to us because that had been foreshadowed
but I still don't feel the previous
episode was worth what we got from it is
alumi and Ty Lee and Kiowas head telling
Kela why he can't win is the best
reverse psychology ever for a boy who's
pumped up on his own abilities but still
forgetting to do some fairly basic
things what prompts him to snap out of
it it's really interesting that he
didn't have that reaction with his Sokka
he simply became filled with dread and
fear having
a drop of blood drawn might be a trigger
for him to end up there but he wasn't in
the mindset of a looming until they were
trapped in a small room and waiting
until the pressure of having to join the
troop began to mount hmm I'll have to
think about that some more because the
reason he went there was really
interesting we know that he fully
snapped out of it because of gone though
gone and his willingness to die for a
friend he believes in the relationships
the two have is almost two halves of the
same coin two halves of the same person
and that's scary but also really cool
the fact that God could explicitly note
exactly how their relationship works
there's a lot about how they care for
each other
and about the fact that they recognize
their foolishness another theme that
I'll go into at some point with this
series I think is the love-hate
push-pull of relationships not
necessarily loving and hating the same
person but the way that relationships
are presented which I find particularly
interesting especially when we think
about how they motivate every
interaction in the show in a way these
kids are finally seriously hunting for
crap because so let's take a look at
episode 51 oh well things have escalated
quickly
sneaky crow low looking exactly like a
really smooth suave ladies man for a
neon why this kid is just caused an
absolute massacre and by staying away
from his fortune she's managed to ensure
that it will happen or at least it will
happen in some way shape or form
fortunes are an interesting thing but
I'm going to assume by this point that
we've been given all the information to
figure it out let's talk through it a
bit before we discuss other things cuz I
love a bit of poetry and I really enjoy
this the calendar loses a precious
component we saw last episode how much
you vodiane was missed and would be
missed by the whole troop the fact that
Corolla even gifts the massacre to him
is a really important point to that and
really cool actually and really enjoyed
that the remaining months gather to
mourn so this is interesting there are
13 phantom troopers but technically
technically it's okay isn't one of them
so there are 12 or 11 without evoking
but including chrono does this mean that
each member of the troop relates to a
month in some way them something I'm
gonna have to consider and I'm really
glad that I have some things to consider
we know there are twelve not eight
members of the Phantom troop maybe
that's for a reason it probably is but
who knows I mean I don't and that's kind
of you know fortunes you get some of the
information but not all of them
Meishan the mourners player melody this
line is pretty clear in literal and
something that I could imagine crawler
was going to do anyway given his
decision to stay to deal with kora pika
while the 11th moon quietly arises okay
now this one I don't know about does
this mean krolow himself does it refer
to his sole care does it refer to
karateka what I know is that it's not
just that it's November that seems odd
and unnecessary then again when karappa
can invoke in fought there was a full
moon this one I'm not sure about does it
mean that crawler will win maybe I mean
it would be the end of an of a series
real fast like I would enter the series
pretty quickly if all of the
protagonists are dead the chrysanthemum
withers and falls to lie on the ground
beside bloody scarlet dies I have no
idea what this means
chrysanthemums the flowers I know that
much bloody scarlet eyes could be
referring to karateka loosing his eyes
or to crap because I simply turning red
I can't imagine they won't turn red when
he's dealing with any member of the
troupe so maybe karapa controller will
fight to the death and simply both die
that's an option you will remain supreme
even after losing half your limbs so
he's gonna lose half of the phantom true
but still succeed in whatever it is he's
trying to do if what he's trying to do
is kill karateka then enjoy the
interlude seek out new allies east is
the direction to cut this isn't poetry
this is just like literally leading out
of a car window
I might where was supposed to go these
lines don't seem to be helpful to our
plucky teenagers who will be seeking to
kill him with great finality but you
know maybe you will find one ooh who
awaits you but who anyway I
I like fortunes I like fortune-telling
it's fun I am always interested to see
how it's twisted and turned anyway good
job neon she walked off immediately got
caught and happily gave a fortune to
someone she didn't know who is
definitely going to want to Massacre her
family and will probably draw the entire
zoldak family interventions once farm
boy arrives don't think I didn't notice
Papa zoldak stare it's just that so many
other things happened my brain skimmed
the importance of it back to the
immediate issue what do we say about the
fact that neon still alive
Frollo knows he could return to her at
any point and ask for another fortune
probably why kill a cow
could keep on giving I'm not saying
she's a cow but this kid if you keep the
nostrils alive for now is a fantastic
resource why fight with that also who is
the ghost crawler was talking about who
is it he wants to bring back the dead
is it the same as melody is it the same
as melody like like is that is that a
thing is that what we're saying like oh
the classical music at the end speaking
of melody the classical music at the end
of the episode was frankly beautiful
while it can become cheesy I really
enjoy the combination of classical music
and violence classical music can so
often be violent as evidenced by his
fortune advising him of melody in the
requiem for the dead at least we know
that for a short time we still have a
melody which is good let's keep hold of
what lightness we can even if she's
drenched in the darkness of this series
the repeated actions of the troupe the
sheer fun of it all in their way they
use their abilities is devastating
seeing them play with people and
desecrate everything about them as they
died was almost numbing it happened so
much and with those strings sitting
under it it really pushed us into the
territory of knowing that we're not
supposed to dwell on any of it it's
supposed to be an outcome not a focus
we've already had the focus on violence
as shown by Crowe Lowe pulling a pen out
of someone's head and we had the focus
on avoiding violence as shown by karapa
car simply putting a clean knife to
someone's throat it was an interesting
artistic choice that one to have the
clean bright knife karateka had not even
his standard weapon then to compare with
Karolos non-standard weapon of a pen it
really showed now that I think about it
the fact that both characters are
hideously dangerous with essentially
mundane tools no a knife is not entirely
mundane but the fact that he was drawn
holding it with his chained hand shows
his restraint in that moment it's
remarkable that his Sokka didn't help at
all or at least didn't get involved does
that mean he has a heart or that he's
decided it's not worth it he's kind of
like a cat half the time what he's doing
is to make others feel good for example
when he gave gone some training before
leaving in other times he's deliberately
pushing people off tables like that time
he pushed a topic off a table sorry that
didn't happen but he did make kylo I
bleed a drop of blood just like an angry
cat claw I'm sure the metaphor works I'm
just not in the best position right now
to deliver it the way the Phantom troupe
delivered a hardcore mess to york-new
that music though continuing straight to
the end of the entire episode was fairly
brutal because it all tied in so well
they're all going to be dragged in in
some way even guns dad wait
even gongs dad may
who knows I don't yet and that's why we
finish up here because that's it from me
I want to watch more if you enjoyed this
mild delve into this really really big
episode there are other things that you
might like to see here and here
hit the like dislike and/or subscribe
button and I found out recently that
there's a bell
hit the bell and be cat like a friend
Hisoka and I'll see you next time